korea where they are playing so i wanted
to say a few words about the playing
location which is amazing
amazing it's huge it's like everything
in dubai everything is beautiful and
nice and huge
and the playing hall itself is something
very huge also the players are actually
sitting behind the glass
wall which is practically sound proof
more or less
and the audience see them
behind the glass wall but actually the
players are not seeing out they don't
see the
audience who are sitting there so
actually they have a very quiet
environment and the place itself for
them the playing area is
pretty big i think it's bigger than
anything before they had in any world
championship match
but definitely something very
comfortable for the players yesterday
there was choosing the chairs also for
the players which one uh wants to sit in
this or that chair
and nowadays it it is a part of the
preparation but let's we should not miss
also you should not miss the whole game
because you know like we
while talking about the uh
playing hall we might miss they're
playing moves at such speed we might
might miss the whole game and then by
the time we are done there they already
finished